[Music]
zelda's 35th anniversary is right around
the corner
and while that doesn't guarantee we'll
get any new information about breath of
the wild sequel anytime
soon there is at least an increased
chance of this happening
if and when nintendo announces a 3d
zelda collection it would be the perfect
opportunity
to share some additional info on the
development of breath the while too
just like they did with the announcement
of twilight princess hd in 2015.
yes anuma did state that we have to wait
a bit longer back when age of calamity
was announced
but that was five months ago what
constitutes as
quote unquote a bit longer i'd say close
to half a year definitely meets that
criteria especially considering that the
initial reveal of the game
is now well over one and a half years
ago time
sure flies with the anniversary now
closing in i thought it would be fitting
to revisit breath while 2's trailer
one last time and talk about something
many have wondered and theorized about
namely where could the entrance to the
underground cave system be
as well as the room where ganondorf is
located well today we will explore
just that uh i mean i i will be
exploring just that what is up
everyone it's your boy hyrulegamer oh
god what have i gotten myself into this
time
oh come on monster man we've been
talking about a collab for a long time
now what better timing than before the
35th anniversary
right but i just did a collab with mass
nintendo bandit
i don't know if this is the right time
i'll give you a free hyrule gamer
t-shirt
damn it sir you strike a hard bargain
you got yourself a deal
take it away before we get into possible
locations we first have to establish
some things about the reveal trailer
itself
monster maze addressed this before in
his video about the chronology of the
trailer
and that is that this doorway we see
right here is likely
not the entrance to the entire cave
system but instead leaves straight into
the room where ganondorf resides
some giveaways are the dim lighting and
rock walls and floor
which hints that this is already deep
underground somewhere but not out in the
open
second are the decorations of what seems
to be a boar-like figure
eerily similar to ganondorf's alter-ego
ganon
there are even more little details that
hint to this being true
but you'll just have to watch monster
maze's video for that which is an
amazing video by the way
just absolutely stunning work wait are
you purposely writing this in the script
to make me praise your video
no well alright then
anyway on to the next point ever since
the trailer premiered at e3 the main
consensus has been that the room where
the corpse is located
is in all probability underneath hyrule
castle somewhere but we do have to keep
in mind that these are just speculations
and nothing more
there was a recent fake leak about
breath of the wild too a supposed
pamphlet published by nintendo
stating that ganondorf is deep within
the caverns underneath hyrule's capital
but this is not legitimate information
it has since been revealed that this
wasn't an official nintendo publication
and wasn't even referring to the sequel
but rather the original breath of the
wild
regardless the chances of this room
being under the castle
is still very likely given calamity
ganon's nature of rising from the depths
of the castle and the fact that we see
malice flowing outwards from the corpse
it is the scenario that holds the most
way where the malice accumulates over
time
slowly building up until there is enough
of it to rise up to the surface and
launch another attack on hyrule's
populace
we also see the malice violently hit the
ceiling only to see hiro castle rise up
a few shots later
however we have to remain open to the
idea that the two events are completely
unrelated
maybe the castle doesn't even rise until
the later stages of the game
who knows until we get more information
on the game anything goes really
despite this we will still base our
predictions on this room being inside or
at least close to the castle
since as stated before based on the
little info we have it is the most
credible option by a long shot
with that in mind if the room containing
the sealed gerudo king is located here
then link and zelda have to be traveling
towards it from somewhere else
and judging by the sheer amount of
equipment they brought with them this
doesn't seem to be a short trip either
some of the things they are carrying
include bundles of wood cooking
equipment
mattresses and what seems to be a steel
lantern which kind of makes me wonder
why they are carrying torches and all
kinds of extra bags filled with other
stuff
from the other angle we can see a box
strapped to the animal in front of the
saddle
and another green tubular shaped object
in front of that which could be a tent
of some kind
we can even see link grabbing something
from one of the bags in this shot
it's not clear what it is even with the
enhancements to the image
but judging from the fact that they are
close to a water source i'd say it's
probably a water satchel to collect some
of that good old
h2o all this combined leads me to
believe that this is a trip spanning
across
multiple days why else would you bring
equipment to spend the night like
mattresses and even entire wood bundles
to build a campfire in real life cavers
usually don't carry equipment like this
as it would just get in the way unless
they are expecting a long expedition on
the ground
if the entrance to this cave system was
close to hyrule castle and say
ganondorf is located right underneath
the astral observatory
as an example you likely wouldn't need
this much stuff not to mention an entire
packing animal they could just dig
straight down into the underground
chamber from the numerous quarries
already present at the castle
instead the evidence suggests that the
cave's actual entrance is somewhere far
away from the capital and lincoln zelda
made a long journey
to ganondorf from there perhaps even
unaware that their path was leading to
the castle's depths
which brings us to the first candidate
in the list the giant hole inside the
yugaclan hideout
this location is definitely far enough
from the castle that it would require a
multi-day caving expedition to get there
some even suggest that this hole was
perhaps created with the sole purpose of
finding ganondorf's whereabouts
as far as locations around hyrule go
this and the chasms surrounding the
grudo tower nearby are the only things
close to a pre-existing underground
entrance with no visible
bottom definitely suspicious to say the
least
but there are also some problems with
this idea it's clear from the trailer
itself that the duo is moving along a
linear path towards their destination
not just a linear path but also a
horizontal one
they don't seem to be caving or
spelunking as it is often referred to
neither link or zelda is wearing a
harness nor are they seen carrying any
ropes
you might say well maybe they do but
they are in one of the bags on the
animal
which raises the question how did the
animal get down there
this creature bears a strong resemblance
to a rhinoceros at least in terms of
size i'd say it's probably even bigger
than that judging from the size
comparison
the average weight of a white rhinoceros
is already around 2
300 kilograms or 2.3 tonnes factor in
all of the equipment it's carrying and
you'd need quite a lot of rope and
effort to get this thing down here
the bottom of the ego hole isn't visible
but we can actually make a rough
estimate of how deep it is
in the champions ballad dlc link needs
to drop an orb into it to reveal a
shrine
after the orb is dropped it takes about
eight seconds until we hear the ball
activating the pedestal
we do hear the ball rattling beforehand
but it's likely hitting the side walls a
couple of times before it lands
it usually takes a second or so for the
pedestal to activate so
let's say seven seconds this is very
crude of course as there are multiple
factors that go into a calculation like
this
like the initial velocity and the ball
hitting the side walls which would slow
down a bit but we're going to do this
lazily
boom seven seconds that is about 240
meters or 780 feet high
two-thirds of the empire state building
or 160 tangles
that is quite a long way down you would
probably need at least three or four
ropes to balance and carry the weight of
this beast
which means close to a kilometer or .6
miles of rope to get the job done
alternatively since this is a fantasy
game they could have used the chica
slate to teleport the animal down i
guess
but first off we don't even know if that
technology is still working at this
point and second
the sheikah slate can only teleport to
shrines towers or a location
set by the travel medallion we know the
shrine is not inside the hole
only the pedestal so the only plausible
way would be if linker zelda climbed
down beforehand
set up a warp point with the medallion
and then teleported the animal down
while this is all possible it seems like
a lot of effort and busy work for
something they don't even know is going
to lead anywhere
so let's look at some alternatives
places that don't require hoisting a
multi-ton animal down and are more easy
to reach
like the underground trial at the great
plateau for instance
yes the shrine of resurrection serves
not only as a medical facility
but the entire room itself is also an
elevator that sends you
quite deep underground a lot more
convenient for bringing a large animal
and heavy equipment with you i would say
the shrine isn't as far from hyrule
castle as the yiga hideout but would
still span
all the way across hyrule field which
could still take a few days to get there
and back again
this would also be a way to have monk
mask kosher play an additional role in
the story
as he is the only monk not to disappear
into thin air once you complete his
test maybe he reveals a hidden path
somewhere in the underground trial which
leads into this cave system
or the elevator can go even further down
then we have two other viable locations
farron or somewhere inside the hebrew
mountains
fahren speaks for itself blah blah blah
zonai
not only would it tie into the zonai
motif we see sprinkled throughout the
underground caves but it would also be
far enough away from the castle to
warrant a long journey on the ground
we've already seen a doorway leading to
a shrine inside the spring of courage
so who's to say there isn't another one
of these doorways located somewhere
inside the dense forest of farren we
even see a bridge down in the caves that
looks like a larger variant of the
sargon bridge found above ground
a hidden entrance like this may lead
down more gently
as opposed to a straight drop or the
need for an elevator instead it would
slowly descend step by step
like a mine shaft next we have the hebra
mountains
care to take this one hg sure why not
now you might be thinking why hebrew of
all places
well once again he's gonna say it secret
doors
oh for a second there i thought you were
gonna say something else secret
zonai doors there we go yes while the
zonai are quite the cliche at this point
we can't ignore the zona architecture
down in the caves
some might think that hebrew doesn't
really have much to do with the zonai
aside from the north loma labyrinth
right
well actually we find a total of two
secret doors leading into the mountains
one leading to a shrine and the other to
the cave containing the hebrew great
skeleton and an additional shrine
in both cases the door features zonai
decorations on it the same ones found on
some of the other structures perhaps
there are more of these doors heading
somewhere within this massive mountain
range
one of which leading down and towards
hyrule castle the only problem here
would be the harsh temperature
i'm not sure if the packing animal could
handle the extreme cold
though we do see the great horned
rhinoceros in this region who have
adapted to the frigid conditions of
hebra
but until we know about this new species
of animal we can't say for sure if they
would be up to the task
either way if the entrance is located
here somewhere it would probably be of a
similar kind as the one found in farron
a gentle descent down into the earth
rather than a deadly drop down into the
abyss
lastly we have some honorable mentions
we have the shika towers themselves who
some furious like hmk have suggested
made double as an elevator leading down
they rose from the deep underground
after all so maybe they can also send us
down
similar to the shrine of resurrection
then we have the forgotten temple which
is already half buried deep inside a
canyon
it too could potentially hold a secret
entrance perhaps behind the giant hylia
statue
speaking of statues the eighth heroine
is another candidate
some believe this statue to represent
ganondorf and if true
what would be a more fitting location
for a secret entrance towards his sealed
corpse
than hidden behind a statue in his honor
those are all great options as well
which reminds me aren't you doing a
video about secret locations hidden
around hyrule i sure am
so if you will head over to my channel
where monster maze and i continue this
journey across
breath of the wild hyrule and look at
five mysterious locations and ruins
across hyrule and go into some mini
theories about them
awesome be sure to go check it out oh
and if you have your own suggestions as
to where this mysterious cave entrance
could be feel free to share them down in
the comments
i'm always interested in new ideas now
we could of course be totally
overthinking this
given the fact that we have so little to
go on maybe link and zelda carry all
this equipment around in case of a
cave-in and they need to spend the night
waiting for rescue
or this entire section isn't even in the
game and it's just part of the teaser
maybe the entrance is actually at hyrule
castle alternatively maybe ganondorf's
bod
isn't even at hyrule castle but in a
completely different location
hopefully we will find out more soon a
huge thanks to hyrulegamer for being my
partner in crime for this one
don't forget to check out his video as
well which will again star us both as we
search for some more secrets around
hyrule
and as always a big thanks to my
patreons and channel members of which
i have one new hero joining the maze
thank you to kiliana brennan for
becoming my latest member
your awesomeness is only matched by your
generosity
thank you for joining and that is all
for now this is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you